president Rafa has never been one to
mince words but he's becoming
particularly aggressive as he continues
to trail Joe Biden in the polls the
media is of course a favorite target
FoxNews media analyst and host of Fox's
media buzz Howard Kurtz takes a look
tonight President Trump hasn't just had
his administration sue John Bolton over
a book he called the former national
security adviser a wacko incompetent a
disgruntled boring fool and a sick puppy
in terms of Bolton he broke the law he
was a washed-up guy I gave him a chance
the president has escalated his attacks
on all kinds of targets selling the
Supreme Court for two decisions he
called shotgun blasts into the face of
Republicans and conservatives one ruling
on gay rights was written by his
appointee Neil Gorsuch president said
Seattle mayor jerry jerkin and
washington governor jay Inslee should be
ashamed of themselves for ceding control
of one area to protesters now the New
York Times escorting unnamed Trump
advisors is saying after he tweeted when
the looting starts the shooting starts
that his political self-sabotage has
damaged his reelection chances and
questioning whether he really wants a
second term what this misses is 2016 and
all the media predictions that Trump's
slashing attacks would doom him and
that's why since his supporters often
overlook his harshest rhetoric he
believes he can prove the establishment
wrong again as for the press the
president accused the far-left fake news
media of trying to Kovich shame in by
focusing on the risks of tomorrow's
Oklahoma rally Twitter itself has felt
the president sting as he's ordered a
legal review of social media firms
Twitter last night slept a manipulated
media warning label on a Trump post of
an obviously fake scene and video with
the tagline America isn't the problem
fake news is the president is often
punching back Bolden's book denounces
Trump as unfit for office CNN's coverage
of him is largely negative and the media
rarely mentioned the coronavirus risk of
the racism protests I would encourage
all of you to cover the protests in the
same way that you covered the rally
goers the president had few defenders
what he went after an injured elderly
Buffalo protester but what's clear is
he's not going to change as the x
coordinate is telling aides who urged
him to tone it down
I have to be myself Mike Howie thanks a
lot